numbers really back that up take a look
since distance education started
20 students have committed suicide
tonight
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how a high school in the valley
is empowering kids to connect with their
peers and potentially
save lives be that person who smiles
an open conversation about mental health
there are no
guarantees that we won't experience a
suicide at spring valley
roughly 30 students in a virtual meeting
are part of hope squad
a peer-to-peer suicide prevention
program in its first year at spring
valley high school
we're not there to solve problems but
we're there to listen
madison alexander and the others started
their training in september
all chosen by their classmates to be a
part of this group
they meet bi-monthly and learn how to
recognize kids struggling and
offer support i have told some teachers
like oh
this student in your class can you ask
them if they are okay
we don't train hope squad members to be
therapists or counselors
we train them to be friends dr greg
hudnall joining the chat
what we want you to be is the eyes and
ears of the school
he created hope squad more than 15 years
ago in utah
after the former high school principal
identified the body of a student
who had taken his life when i got done i
walked to my car and
i literally threw up and saw i made a
vow that i would do everything i could
to help
prevent suicide so making good on his
promise more than 950 schools
nationwide and in canada use the program
spring valley making the choice before
the pandemic to start hope squad
and it's making a difference as more
students deal with isolation during
distance education
we've already had some success stories
that the advisor has shared with me
focusing on help and giving hope when
students need it most
kristin drummond 8 news now there are
roughly
15 hope squads at ccsd schools according
to hudnall he had 7 out of 10
children experiencing depressive or
suicidal thoughts
will confide in a friend or trusted peer
before
approaching an adult